hello my name is zach smith i'd like to
welcome you to our online webinar about
increasing productivity and
reproducibility by automating DNA
library prep for ion torrent sequencing
i'm joined today by dr. Joanna hamilton
from dartmouth and Dr Lin apone from New
England Biolabs and we're very pleased
to have them here and thank you for
joining us and with that I would like to
begin this talk by passing the
presentation off to dr. pone thank you
very much Zach um I know I thank
everyone for attending the seminar I'm
going to begin by so I'm having a little
problem with moving the slides there we
go so I followed us so I'm going to
begin I'm going to talk a little bit
about one of the kids we developed at
any be 4i infant library construction
but what I'd like to do is begin with
just an overview of the workflow and and
describe the steps involved in
generating a library for I in torrance
sequencing so the first step involves
fragmentation of the input DNA those
fragments are then and repaired to
generate 55 plus correlated blunt-ended
molecules onto those molecules of
ligated the p1 and a adapter in this
system the adapters are not
phosphorylated and that aids in reducing
the amount of adapted diamond is
produced but it causes an incomplete or
result in an incomplete ligation so
there are Nick's remaining in the DNA
after the ligation that have to be
repaired and those are repaired by a
nick translation reaction so following
the new translation the library is
enriched my amplifying in a PCR reaction
and so there's a number of steps that
occurred during library construction and
after each one of these steps there's
typically a clean up that occurs and
also after the ligation and nick we pay
is also a size selection and over there
and I'm cleaner so when we were
developing a kid in NB we had a number
of goals that we set for our kid yeah
and the goals we wanted to have for to
develop a fast and simple protocol that
would minimize hands-on time as well as
the ability or the possibility of errors
we also wanted to eliminate the need to
fragment DNA before going into library
prep so we wanted to have as our input
intact DNA and of course we wanted to
create a low-cost solution for our
customers and so the kit we developed is
called the enemy next fast DNA
fragmentation and library prep said and
what we've done with this kit is we've
combined the fragmentation and end
repair into one step and this allows us
to use as input intact DNA we also had
this on this particular cup is able to
be inactivated with heat and so that we
moves the need to clean up the sample
after this step we've also combined the
ligation as well as the nick translation
step and that allows for the
construction of PCR through the
libraries and so after the ligation a
nick translation step the sample is
cleaned up and size selected and then
the simple can either be sequence
directly or it can be enriched in PCR
amplification so you feel we've reached
our goals with this kid we have a simple
protocol with a streamlined workflow
it's fast it takes about two hours to
make a library and there's very little
hands-on time involved the kit is
compatible with a broad range of
influence from ten nanograms to one
microgram and it's compatible with
multiplexing and as I said PC out free
library construction this kid is also
compatible with a broad range of inputs
so I'm showing you libraries that were
constructed from DNA isolated from
different organisms and the GC content
in these organisms range from
thirty-eight percent to sixty-five
percent and I'm also showing you that
the kid can be used to construct
libraries
of different sizes so in this particular
library construction a single prep was
made for each library and that was one
on an e gel to size select and a 200
base pair size library was alluded first
the gel was 14 but Margaret and then the
plan of a spirit library building so
this versatility there in addition the
libraries that are generated with the
kid produce very high quality sequencing
data so I'm showing you a snapshot of
one of our run reports for our library
one of our libraries this was a 200 base
pair library that massage selected in
jail so you can see that the read length
distribution is quite tight and the data
that was produced very high quality it
shows very high matching to the genome
and good quality this in our kit we also
have a protocol for each size selection
of the libraries and this would give a
much broader size distribution and so we
think we have a kit that is has a has a
streamlined workflow it's fast it's easy
and it produces very high quality I
insolent libraries and so thank you and
I am going to i think pass control back
to that
Thank You Lynn so I am going to talk
about some of the work that we'd perform
here beckman coulter to automate this
protocol so the protocol in question was
automated on our biomech 4000 liquid
handler which is the smallest of our
biomech platforms largely by Sarah
Simon's one of our very capable field
application scientists so what I'm
showing here is the deck layout of those
required by the method we have the
standard biomech 4000 deck setup except
for we have added an orbital shaker at
this position and then we were using the
gripper and a variety of tools the
method itself has a HTML driven user
interface that's very straightforward to
use we have the ability to set the
number of samples from one sample up to
48 samples in any combination thereof so
you could if you wanted to do 23 samples
you could do 23 samples and then what
you'll do next is select which workflow
that you wanted to pursue either
fragmentation and ligation size
selection PCR or post pcr cleanup based
on what new information you feed the
user interface there we go there's our
two arrows pointing out the two points
of the HTML user interface the method
will then pop up an HTML driven reagent
calculator that shows you what to put on
the for example the 24 positioned to
brac and how to make those things that
you're putting on the tube rack so these
are complete master mix recipes that
take into account the number of samples
being processed and the required dead
volumes for the pipetting and lab where
that's being used and how much of our
ampere XP reagent and ethanol and
resuspension buffer to load in our
reservoirs so it gives you a very
detailed overview as to what the actual
consumables will be required on the deck
and then also depending on which
workflow you selected the instrument
will then pop up the required deck for
any of the individual workflows so this
is the workflow for fragmentation and
library
orientation and legation they then have
on the upper right of the 14 size
selection followed by the bottom left
which is pcr setup and then finally the
post-pc are clean up so it doesn't
require a whole lot of lab where the
method has been written in such a way is
to use partial plate transfers and so if
we're doing up to 48 samples it will run
for example one clean up in columns one
through six and then transfer column 1 2
column 7 of the same plate and then use
column 7 through 12 for the second clean
up this as the ability to allow the user
to cut down on the amount of required
lab where it makes for some pretty good
slick code so with that I'm going to
pass the presentation over to dr.
Hamilton of Dartmouth purpose okay thank
you zach and lynn for that introduction
and thank you everybody for listening to
our presentation today i'm going to talk
to you about how we have used these
methods in our core facility so we're
located in Lebanon New Hampshire and we
have a fairly small genomics core
facility and we also have a sister
facility that does Sanger sequencing but
within within my core we are doing the
add the DNA sequencing and micro arrays
and there's really three of us that are
working in that capacity so at Dartmouth
we recently purchased the Ion Torrent
sequencing platform we have both the PGM
and the proton sequences the PGM is the
lower capacity sequencer for
predominantly targeted sequencing
applications and the proton sequencer is
a higher capacity sequence so that we
can use for whole exome sequencing some
RNA seek and the data that i'm going to
show you today was from the proton
sequencer
so here i'm just showing the Ion Torrent
workflow we start off with DNA that we
that we make for a that we need to
fragment and then make a library prep
once we have the library prepared we
then template this on to isp beads which
is part of the Ion Torrent platform we
do that on the one-touch instrument once
we have the DNA on the beads and ideally
we have one unique piece of DNA on each
of the beads so that we are able to
distinguish the sequence once it comes
off the sequencer the beads are then
loaded into the they are loaded into
each well on the semiconductor chip and
then we perform the sequencing which
takes anywhere from two hours 24 hours
depending on the read length and then
we're using the Ion Torrent browser and
a number of downstream analysis tools to
run the analysis so the major bottleneck
that we have at Dartmouth is really in
the library preparation step so for each
biological sample a unique library needs
to be prepared and doing that by hand is
often time consuming we only do perhaps
eight or ten library perhaps at a time
manually and we would like to increase
this productivity here at this step and
so we went ahead and purchased the
biomech 4000 we were hopeful that this
would help us with many of our protocols
as well as the NGS sequencing we worked
with Sarah Simon's very closely to write
the methods for a number of NGOs
applications and she came on site and
visited with us and really helped us set
up the method so it was very easy for us
to be able to do this Sarah helped us
water test all the methods before she
left us with the instrument and so we
were very capable of running the
instrument fairly quickly after
methods were installed and another nice
thing that Beckman did for us was they
created a word document which provide
detailed explanations of exactly how we
were to run the protocol which was what
was needed at which steps so that it
made it easy for us to use so within our
cool we offer a number of different
sequencing services before the project
begins we meet with our investigator and
the bioinformatics core so that we can
really get a good understanding of what
the project is and then when we receive
the sample we do some quality control we
Nana drop and cube it everything that
comes into the lab we also fragment
analyze all the DNA so that we know
we're starting with high quality samples
we have an internal billing system where
customers can place the order we can
also work with external customers as
well we may want to do some services
that we offer and we can set that system
up for them as well and then once we are
satisfied that the sample is high enough
quality to go on into the process we'll
go ahead and do the entire workflow and
then provide the results to the
investigator and often in association
with the bioinformatics court here as
well so some of the services that we
offer we offer RNA transcription
profiling and we still do do many micro
arrays but we're also doing a lot of RNA
seek as well as some micro RNA work as
well but today what I'm going to
predominantly talk about is the the DNA
sequencing that we can perform so we can
do whole genome sequencing for small for
small species and I'm going to talk a
little bit about that and we can also do
custom panels which is another thing
that we have optimized for our
sequencing and also on the biomed 4000
so first of all I'm going to talk to you
about the
any big workflow that we automated so
several months ago and investigator
approach test and they had a for us a
fairly large DNA sequencing project with
a hundred and seventy biological samples
these were bacterial samples and they
wanted to do whole genome sequencing
because the genome of the bacteria of
interest is fairly small we were able to
multiplex this fairly highly and we took
advantage of the full range of 96
barcodes that's available from Ion
Torrent we had used the any be next
workflow in the core previously for
projects before this and we were you
know happy with the workflow we had
generated good libraries and so we
decided that this was a good opportunity
to try to automate this of course with
all investigators that wanted the data
as soon as possible and with the grant
deadline approaching we actually ended
up starting a lot of the libraries
manually while Sarah was working on the
methods and so we have a very nice data
set with large the large end that we are
able to compare because of this
fortuitous time frame that we set up
this experiment with and so I'm going to
go on and show you really how we did
this Lynn already mentioned this is the
any be library prep so I'll just go into
it in a little more detail setting up
the reaction and then we do not have
kavars instrument here so we needed to
use a prep where we could fragment the
DNA as well and so we liked this kit
because we were able to do the
fragmentation reaction at the same time
so we then do the fragmentation and then
prepare step and then this is done
really within the PCR instrument
themselves and so there's not too much
hands-on time for that but obviously the
pipe cutting if you're going to have a
lot of samples does add to this time and
so then the Ion Torrent adapters are
added and then for this instance we're
using the XP bead cleanups and not that
Jones and we're doing a 200 base pairs
sequencing since that's what's available
available to us on the ion proton
sequencer we did do limited PCR cycling
for our for our samples and the idea for
automating this was really to try to
increase our turnaround time for our
library preparations to be able to
produce more libraries in one in one go
rather than just the eight or ten that
we would prepare manually to try to
avoid any human error being introduced
also we were hoping that the automation
would increase the reproducibility of
our preparations and result in fewer
errors so the setup that we did for the
first batch of manual preparations at
most we prepared ten libraries at a time
and so here I just have depicted the
time course of how long it would really
take to prepare eighty libraries which
would really take you know if each of
these bars is is a day it would take us
eight or nine days to prepare this of
course that's if we're working on only
this project so here's our automated
timeline that we used for this project
and how we optimize this protocol so the
first time we did it we just did eight
samples and then we increase that to 24
preparations at a time in in one sitting
so you can see already we're having the
time that it would take to make the same
number of libraries and I propose that
you could do 48 at a time and again
you're going to really reduce the time
that it's going to take to make for
example 96 libraries to sequence and so
as Zack mentioned the way that the
protocol was set up it was set up to be
modular so that we could run anywhere
from 8 or 12 48 samples and you could
select each step depending on where you
were in the protocol we used all 96
barcodes from from life technologies I'm
torrent the ion express DNA barcodes and
on the left here i'm just showing really
how complicated the protocol is if you
were to try to try to write this
yourself luckily we had Sarah helping us
here and some of the nice features that
we weren't able to include we have our
instrument set up in a location where
it's not ranked next to the lab and so
we even incorporated some custom music
at the end of the run down here so that
we could hear that the instrument was
completed and efficiently put it at the
next step so the first step of the
protocol is basically setting up the
fragmentation reaction and so the DNA is
set up here in a sample plate this step
is set up manually with the one with 40
up to 48 samples in the plate and then
the ligation reactions are added the
fragmentation and ligation reactions are
added from the reagent tubes which are
on chiller plates and another nice
feature that we have is when the machine
is completed doing all of the pipe
cutting steps a message pops up which
tells you exactly what you need to do
next so you don't need to have the paper
manual or protocol right in front of you
you you can rely on the software telling
you what to do so here the next step was
to put it in a thermocycler it tells you
the temperature controls that you need
to do and it also tells you what to do
once you put the once you put the
instrument the plates back on the
machine it tells you when and load those
as well so
second step is the adapter ligation and
you end up replacing the plate here
replacing the plate on the orbital
shaker and all of these figures I've
taken from a document that Sarah put
together for us which really outlines
the deck layer so again is it sort of
creating it so that it's it's not very
easy to make a mistake which is which is
great and then we have a plate with the
96 adapters or 48 adapters in this case
are uniquely loaded here and then the
reaction proceeds from there in that
plate with the new adapters and again at
the end of that we have a prompt telling
us exactly what to do with the sample
and which stage where at in the protocol
so we use the XP beads for cleaning up
cleaning up the reaction and we did this
in a reservoir so there is a little bit
of overage that you need to account for
when you're using the reservoirs but
this was reusable we made sure that
everything was sterile before we put it
in so that we could reuse any unused am
pure beads or ethanol that we put in the
reservoirs and then the we also have the
cleanup plate set up here and we also
have the magnet which we set up right on
the deck so that the gripper is able to
take the plane from the orbital shaker
and put it directly on the magnet so
that we can we can do all of that on the
deck so after the cleanup step we go on
to set up the PCR step and the master
mix is then added to a chilled plate and
again this is all set up with in 96-well
plates on the instrument
and it tells us exactly what we need to
do to put it in the pcr machine
afterwards there is a second cleanup
step after the PCR again we're using the
same setup as before where we're using
the ampere XP beads and the magnet and
once our protocol is complete there's
the music of course and then a note that
tells us we've completed the protocol it
is also telling us that there are dirty
tips and make sure you discard if the
dirty tips and then these libraries are
ready for QC and sequencing so once we
have we've done this are the QC that we
do is usually qubit and fragment analyze
it to determine how we're going to
sequence these libraries so I'll go on
and show you a little bit about one of
the projects that we've done again it
was a large project with about 170
samples we have some patient-derived
bacterial DNA we started the perhaps
with a hundred nanograms but we have
gone as low as 10 nanograms and seen
very good results for this as well as
i've mentioned we incorporated the iron
express DNA barcodes we are using the
iron proton to do the sequencing here
and we use the version three most recent
chemistry for doing 200 base pairs
sequencing so we really wanted to get a
fairly tight library distributed right
around the 200 base pairs and we
amplified this to eight cycles during
the preparation so here i'm showing a
comparison of two libraries generated
with the NEP next protocol only the
beckman the biomech 4000 the top panel
is a manually prepared library and the
bottom panel is the Beckman prepared
library
excuse me what you can see is that the
software actually for the fragment
analyzer is different in these two cases
and so this is why these looks do look
slightly different but I think you can
see that both preparations have very
nice distribution between about a
hundred and three hundred base pairs
here it's a little tighter of a
distribution for the automated libraries
which is great since the distribution of
the library is important for the
emulsion PCR amplification on the beads
for I in torrance sequencing and so here
i'm just showing the results of some of
our library perhaps we actually prepared
83 libraries manually and 84 libraries
on the Beckman and these are the result
of that so the yield for the manual
libraries does um typically generate a
larger library or more library sorry but
this is is more variable you can see
that the error bars here are a little
broader than than that for the the red
biomech prepared libraries but even the
even with the yield being a little less
for the biomech libraries there are
plenty as plenty of library to sequence
and so i don't really think that that's
too much of an issue the size
distribution of the beckman libraries
was much tighter so we really didn't see
the variation here with the automated
library perhaps and the size of and the
libraries themselves was a little larger
than the manually prepared libraries I'm
guessing this is during the XP cleanup
step maybe because the ethanol is out in
a reservoir perhaps that affects some of
the size selection here but that that
really doesn't we're still within a good
range of library size four
so I in turn sequencing here so we went
on and prepared a multiplexed reaction
of anywhere from 83 to 96 libraries for
sequencing on the Iron proton and here
i'm just showing the result of that the
previous data that lynn showed was for
sequencing on the inp GM and so this kit
is compatible with PGM and proton
sequencing you can see here on the left
is the bead loading and on the right as
the read length that were generating so
with the libraries that we've prepared
we're getting about 145 base pairs of
sequencing but that does extend up out
past 250 for some for some sequencing
types and I just also was looking wanted
to look at exactly what the sequencing
readout was and so what I what I put
together was how variable the how
variable the recounts were for the
manually prepared and the biomech
prepared libraries and so in independent
of how we prepared the libraries the
same same technicians set up the
multiplexing dilutions for the
sequencing reaction and so really what
this figure is showing is that the
number of reads that are generated for
any given sample are more broadly
distributed than in the manual perhaps
than in in the biomech preps and I think
this just speaks to the fact that if you
have a more tighter library prep and
more common parameters for each of your
libraries that the the sequencing itself
does benefit from that as well so in the
manual preps we did have several samples
that had very few reads and some that
had had a large number of reads based
only and based on the way that we
multiplex these together and so I think
this also
increases the increases our confidence
that the biomech libraries really are
helping us in this regard and we don't
need to repeat any of the sequencing
based on some of the QC problems that we
might have seen with some of these
libraries in the manual press so just to
summarize for the any be part of my talk
here's a summary of how many biological
samples we prepared for this project so
in the for the manual preps we actually
had 83 biological samples however we
needed to repeat 14 samples we had
fourteen failed libraries when we made
these by hand either due to well mostly
due to human error at a certain step it
was either an entire batch failed or one
or two libraries within a manual batch
failed at any time so we did in fact
need to make 97 libraries to get the 83
libraries to sequence the cost of
reagents for this was around 2500
dollars so automatically we we had an
extra cost just for being having to
repeat the libraries from start to
finish bearing in mind we were doing
other projects of course at the same
time it took us 28 days to make the 83
or 97 libraries manually around and two
technicians worked on this together and
in comparison the automated libraries we
have zero failed libraries which was
great every single library that we made
on the Beckman work first time so the
cost of reagents to repeat that was
nothing and we were able to make the
83-84 libraries in over an 11 day period
and it was just one technician working
on this and I did not calculate the the
labor costs associated with the extra
time but I think you can see that this
really has increased our productivity
for making these making this method
automated
I also wanted to talk about another
project that we've automated on them on
the biomech 4000 at the norris cotton
Cancer Center we have several
investigators that were interested in
looking at DNA sequencing for their
favorite gene of interest for example
and so we created a custom cancer gene
panel which consists of 541 genes as
identified by our investigators um this
doesn't come encompass the entire
comprehensive cancer panel that's
offered by Life Technologies the two
options at the time when we set this up
which was over a year ago now that we
really had available to us where to use
the agilent haydel plex panel or we
could use the Ion Torrent and please
seek the eye into an empty seat
chemistry however with that chemistry we
were committed to purchase 7000
reactions then for a small coal facility
that was really a little too many
reactions for us to justify the upfront
cost and so we opted for the agilent
halo plex the agilent halo plex
technology and again we did this on the
ion proton and with 200 base pairs
sequencing the plan was to try to get
around 300 x coverage to be able to
detect rare variants and for that we
needed to use the proton so here is a
list I don't know that you can
necessarily read it but here's a list of
the 541 genes that we wanted to look at
compass a many of the known oncogenes
and tumor suppressor genes that many
cancer research investigators are
interested in so the design itself was
541 target genes which was resolved to
9800 regions when taking into account
the different different sites that we
could look at and also different
different variants as well
and so this was 186,000 articles the way
that it was designed was a paired end
design so that we could look at in both
direction for each of the genes on the
panel that's one thing that iron torrent
doesn't have the ability to do is paired
end sequencing and so this was
attractive to us to be able to do this
as well so the way that the protocol
works is the first step is to digest in
DNA to the DNA and then there is a
circularization and hybridization
reaction that allows us to hybridize the
regions of interest that we want in our
capture and then following that there's
pcr amplification to generate the
library for the sequencing and so this
reaction is very labor-intensive the
first step is setting up an eight
reaction or an 888 restriction digests
for each biological sample and so you
can only do 12 biological samples and
there will be an entire 96-well plate
and of course there's room for error as
you add these restriction enzymes and
also the master mix so really our
rationale for automating this was very
different from our rationale for
eliminating the ad be the only be we
wanted to be able to increase our
turnaround times and do more samples
that we could do manually so this our
rationale was really to just try to
remove that potential for human error
and to be able to generate a more
consistent library prep so again working
with Sarah Simon's from beckman we
automated this method we also created a
modular protocol so that we were able to
run this over a number of days the first
step is actually the overnight
hybridization and so we didn't want to
have to have the protocol running or
pause whilst that was going on so we set
it up to be a modular and at first we
set it up for
128 samples and here is the here i'm
just showing the deck layout so for this
protocol as well which is very similar
in order to eliminate the human error
zach already touched on that they were
read reagent calculators which really
tell us exactly what to add at which
step and which two-bit goes in to on on
the machine and this this is modified
depending on the number of samples that
we put in so if we're doing two
libraries these reaction volumes will be
different compared to doing eight
libraries for example and so that's
going to also eliminate any human error
during the processing and here's another
little little message telling us exactly
what we need to do next with our sample
at a certain step in the protocol so i'm
just showing here the different deck
layouts and the different tools and
instruments that we've been using to set
up these protocols so we have a chill
plate and anna magnets here so those are
important for both for some of the steps
in the halo plex as well and then also
just showing that we can use a reservoir
for different different clean up steps
and for reagents that you can use a
larger volume for
first step after the restriction digest
there is a confirmation step on the
fragment analyzer and here i'm just
showing that independent of whether we
prepared this step manually or on the
biomedical thousand the restriction
digest patent is the same across the
eight restriction digest reaction mixes
and so after that first step we always
run it on the Simon analyzer to just
ensure that the libraries that we're
going to prepare are going to be going
to work and we run a positive control as
well it's provided in the kit at every
every batch that we prepare so that we
know that things are working out we for
this experiment we did compare the same
exact biological sample prepared either
manually or on the biomech 4000 and here
i'm just showing the library profile of
that the profile of the halo flex
libraries is a little broader than the
enemy libraries and so this range is
anywhere from about 150 to about six
hundred base pairs at first we were a
little concerned that the 600 base pairs
may impair the sequencing since with the
emulsion PCR and eyen torrance
recommendations are that the library is
distributed more on the two to three
hundred base pairs size range but we
didn't have any problems with the
sequencing and i'll go ahead and show
you some of the sequencing results at
the moment but we got very good
sequencing from both the biomech and the
manual libraries um when comparing these
the library size was equivalent between
our preparation methods however the
yield for the x over 4000 was in some
cases half of the amount that we got
manually again this is plenty to
sequence I think it just is based on the
fact that when you're preparing them
manually you're more conscious of mixing
that they need and making sure you get
the very last drop of reaction out of
the out of the well whereas when that
happens on the back then there may be a
little bit of
leftover one or two microliters in each
of the reaction steps and as you do that
over four or five different different
parts of the protocol you may lose a
little bit of material but again it's
plenty of material to sequence so here
are the sequencing results that we some
of the results that we got sequencing on
the Iron proton this was with the v2
chemistry so it was the earlier version
of the chemistry we were very happy
because we were getting pretty good
polyclonal numbers and around the
seventeen percent which for ioan torrent
anything less than about thirty percent
is is really good so these libraries are
even though they were broader
distribution didn't really seem to
affect the sequencing ability and we
were able to multiplex five samples on
the sequencing run and get about 400 x
coverage for each sample for these 541
genes on our targeted panel here i'm
just showing the home target percents
and the uniformity percent for the
various prepared libraries and you can
see there they're equivalent and so we
were very happy with these these results
so some things that we did are working
with Becklund to modify the protocol
after we had set it up we increased it
from eight to 12 samples to be able to
fill the entire 96-well plate we
consistently do a second wash for the
halo Plex protocol at the end to remove
adapted Imus and we incorporated that
would likely as well and we modified the
timing to allow for a little bit more
ethanol evaporation during the library
prep which we suspected may have been
having a little effect on the yield and
I didn't mention before but we we
actually didn't have to modify the enemy
protocol at all the one that Sarah
produced for us worked worked very well
so there were no modifications on that
but it was a little bit more of a
straight forward protocol to automate
so just to summarize for the hail plex
we definitely increased the accuracy of
our library perhaps again we had library
perhaps that were produced manually that
we had to repeat because of app because
of human error and so with this we
really have very little repeating
library perhaps which is great and the
lower yield doesn't seem to affect the
sequencing ability at all we have also
optimized this with ffpe DNA as well and
so we did a project with about 25
samples for ffpe and and that worked
very nicely to to the halo plans so just
to summarize my talk today for us
automating these two protocols has
resulted in less human error and more
reliable library preps in addition to
the cost saving and it are in addition
to the time saving for the enemy it has
been cost effective since we're now not
having to repeat libraries and it does
allow us to have one technician working
on this and doing more library preps and
another technician can be doing
something else working with Beckman has
been great especially working with sarah
she has come up to Dartmouth many times
and really helped us get started on this
instrument since there's only three of
us in the lab that was really really
appreciated and some of the other
applications that were working on and
areas where we feel that we can use this
instrument dallas streamlined some of
our processes we're doing the ampli seek
XOM library prep for my intent and we're
working on automating that we have the
fragment analyzer that i mentioned where
week you see on our samples with this
and so we would like to automate the set
up for that that's into a 96-well plate
with a standard fix for each sample and
then the samples on top we think that
could be automated as well as well as
setting up qpcr into a 384-well plate I
would also working on that
well and so with that I thank you for
listening to our presentation I would
just like to acknowledge all the people
at Dartmouth who have worked with me and
really done a little work especially
Heidi Trask and Christian Lydell who
really worked with Sarah on the robot
and then I'll bioinformatics team zhang
jun zhao who does most of our analysis
and then both any be in beckman for
working with me and inviting me to
present today and so i think we have
some time for some questions so i'll
pass it back to Zach who can facilitate
this thank you
there we go so for the question and
answer session we do have a question and
answer section of the site that you can
go to to submit your questions to us we
have received a few questions already
and so I will begin getting those
answered so our first question involves
how much starting DNA is needed for the
any being fast frag and library prep kit
and for the halo flex protocols I can
answer that one straight off the bat so
for the fast frag and a library prep set
for any be the method supports anywhere
from ten nanograms to one microgram of
starting material and for the halo plex
we're using the kit supported 225
nanograms per sample so that that's
pretty much to xscape that one um so
another question we have received
involves how random is the DNA
fragmentation achieve by the fast
fraggin library prep kit and for that
one I'm going to pass the presentation
over to dr. apone dr appt own hi thank
you so i am a fragmentation mix we have
two enzymes one that randomly fragments
DNA and the other that cuts across from
or randomly Nick's DNA sorry and then
one that cuts across from that random
neck also produces brand random
fragments when we compare sequence
coverage to targets using the
fragmentation mix compared to mechanical
share and we don't see any bias and
coverage so we believe that it is in
fact random and there have been a few
independent publications looking at this
issue that we're happy to send you
citations for if you on soon as you know
and I'm going to send this back to them
thank you very much doctor thank you
very much Lynn so another question we
have received is is it possible to use
co varus with this library prep method
rather than the enzyme-based
fragmentation I can answer that one
currently the method is designed to work
with the fragmentation as a solution in
the kit but it could be modified fairly
straight and you know fairly easily to
accommodate cavero steered samples okay
so another question we have received is
is this sodomized is there an automation
method for the fast fraggin library prep
set for other biomech platforms I can
answer that one as well we do have a
solution for the fast frag and library
prep set on the biomech fxp that it's
currently actually installed at a site
and is available for the customers to
use this method for the be 4k and for
halo Flex is also available right now
that we could install a customer sites
so so the next question we have received
is can you get copy number information
from Halo flex with that I am going to
turn the presentation over to dr.
Hamilton and Hamilton and thank you yes
I'm not a hundred percent sure about the
copy number information I think you
would need to run a number of normal
controls for any of the cnv analysis
that we do with ion torrent you would
have to have a number of controls and it
may be that because we're looking for
for deeper coverage here that the copy
number analysis tools may not be
available for this but again I'm not a
hundred percent sure but we would need
to check with with Agilent I think for
that so thank you
Thank You Joanna another question we
have received is what was the total
turnaround time to prep 48 samples using
the NEP next kid on the biomech so the
total machine time is about four hours
for 48 samples however that doesn't
include all the prep work that's
necessary to get those 48 samples on to
the instrument I'd like to go back to
dr. Hamilton and get her input and see
how uh how it is performed in her lab is
performing yeah Thank You Zach um we
actually didn't do 48 samples at one
time the most that we did was 24 and we
reckoned that would take about three
hours um which included the only really
the only manual prep setup is the first
step we put the DNA into the 96-well
plate to start with everything else is
done on the deck and that takes about
three hours for 24 samples so yeah I
imagine if the the robots not going to
take too much longer for the 48 and the
manual step wouldn't be much more so I
think four hours sounds definitely very
reasonable for that I think you could do
to to perhaps add a very physically
thank you very much Joanna um and so
with that I would like to revisit a
previous question about using cavero
shared samples so I would like to give
dr. Epona chance to weigh in on that one
well thank you very thank you very much
I just want to mention that we do have a
kid we do offer a kit in which the input
is DNA that's already fragmented from
any way that that is necessary okay
thank you
okay well if there are no other
questions I think that concludes our
presentation here today I'd like to
thank each and every one of you for
showing up and listening to our talk and
like to also thank dr. Joanna Hamilton
from Dartmouth and dr. Linda pone from
New England Biolabs for presenting I'm
Zack Smith from beckman coulter and
thank you very much